yeah I've noticed there's like two types
of girls that like after abortion like
one gets like really caught up about it
and one doesn't even seem to care and I
don't maybe she's just fronting but I
wonder if it's like an evolutionary
adaptation because historically
um if if you got like taken by another
tribe they would kill the women and the
chip like they would take the women and
kill the children
and that that's like what that I think
it's like might be an evolutionary
adaptation
um do you think that women should be
prosecuted if they have an abortion
um yeah I think if um I I think that the
information should be out there but if I
I think if they outlawed abortion moving
forward they should because a full like
life sentence in jail yeah um if they
because to me it's you either believe
it's a life or you believe it's not a
life and if you believe it's a life if
we like under the law if we recognized
uh like I don't want to say fetus but
like the baby as like a life I just
think it would only make sense to
prosecute it to the fullest extent of
the law but that life can't look after
itself like if you're not able as a life
to look after another life how are you
to be expected to do that I mean neither
can a two-day old baby but you get
prosecuted to the fullest extent of the
law if you kill the baby what about
um like children like young girls that
have been like great so essays like say
you're 11 or 12 and you know you feel
all pregnant Robin's if a 11 or a 12
year old had an abortion would you put
hair in jail for murder
um I mean I try to avoid like the worst
case scenarios because 40 of abortions
um they've had one or more so it's not
like a one-time
like a one-time situation in less than
one percent of abortions are for grape
um but I think it's kind of the similar
to if um but it can happen no okay I'm
gonna answer don't worry
um it's kind of similar to if a kid is
too young like they can go to juvie
um but no I mean it it's really like sad
but I just think that if you're gonna
recognize it as a life like it has to be
consistent legally
can I ask you that question back because
I can see you've got like a real heart
of compassion you know but um in terms
of if you if we were to make abortions
illegal except for grape sexual abuse
so sorry
um and all of these difficult cases
disability then would you agree that we
make it illegal for for just say
contraception using it as contraception
or just because
no still no I still say it's the woman's
Choice up until you say that you're
allowed to it it has to be what human it
is it is interesting because people
often hide behind these difficult cases
um when actually you know you're the
reason is that you you'd be quite happy
for a woman to have an abortion just
because maybe she wants to go on holiday
and if she doesn't if she has a baby
will interrupt her planned holiday
is that a good word is that a good
reason obviously that's not a good
reason but but what I'm not saying just
use abortion as like a form of
contraception but I'm saying like what
but why not
well what was wrong with it why why not
use it as a form of contraception it's
not like it kills a child well no but I
just think that's just like
irresponsible if you were like going out
every weekend getting pregnant and then
like the next week or next month just
going to the clinic and getting an
abortion like but why not what's wrong
what's wrong with abortion that you've
recognized that it shouldn't be used as
contraception well I mean it'll probably
just wouldn't would that even be healthy
for a woman if she was getting an
abortion like I mean neither are plan
B's but girls be taking those every
other day
it's con like just something to think
about you know yeah it is but like I
said I don't think my opinion would
change
contraception is a prevention
yeah
yeah and abortion isn't
I think men should have these pills
because they can get 365 women pregnant
in a year and a woman can only get
pregnant
I think that's a big spread our seed
okay I think
I feel like there's a like I don't know
why they haven't come up with that yet
they haven't they have they have but men
decline but they won't take it no like
it had two that one that's what they say
but it had too many side effects like it
was like no I'm talking like it's
sterilized I got like it was actually
like too much yeah like it was I don't
remember off the top of my head but it
was actually really bad
um I don't remember one guy that got
sterilized or die like something really
serious happened and it wasn't that big
of a sample size so like if it was one
out of 20 you know that that might
happen to you you probably aren't going
to take it
um but I'm butchering that that's just
like off the top of my head
um do you guys think that men should
have a say an abortion so
um further for the pro-choice people so
if you get pregnant and um the father of
the kid wants you to keep it should he
have any say
like if I was in a serious relationship
um
I mean of course he can have his opinion
but
I think like I said it's down to the
woman
to do whatever she wants to do so even
if he said no I don't want you to get an
abortion I think even if she wants to
get one she should still be able to get
one because at the end of the day it's
hey let's carrying the baby
um yeah
okay let's give him birth so yeah I
think it's her choice yeah I would agree
with you and also like who's human
rights are we
thinking about here you know your whole
life changes if you have a baby
like if you're men and for a woman yeah
for all parties involved and not even
just the man and the woman the superior
The Wider family and the child what if
the dad says like uh you don't once you
give birth like you don't have to I'll
take care of it I don't I don't need you
to do anything else like I got it can
you carry it for me can you buff it for
me
can you change your body for me
do you know how many times you hear
about like dad's running out on like
sing like mums and they're like oh I
swear it took two of us to meet this kid
like come back here and like look after
the kid so that is acceptable for the
woman to see but when it comes to like
deciding on who's like gonna have the
baby no no it's definitely my choice
this is what I mean and then like ah
like I didn't even expect us to go into
the whole men and women's hacker debate
and I thought we were going to stick to
abortion but it's again like it's just
double standards isn't it you know you
guys want basically everything and then
more and you don't carry it you don't
have to well you don't carry it but
what's worse though carrying it or
paying for it for the rest of its life
and paying non-stop child support paying
everyone so you're saying that women
don't pay for their children
well I'm saying no most of the time if
the man is involved he's paying for very
much everything right if he's a student
no if he's a supporting that if he's
disappointed as supporting means
supporting the person that's actually
doing
sorry
if I'm in the kid's life I'm gonna have
to make sure I'm working to look after
that kid subjectively yeah not
objectively wait hold on say that again
that's you subjectively yeah well I'm
just talking about what a high value man
would want to do for their wife I don't
want personally a high value man would
want to do but statistically is that
what happens well yeah so why are there
so many singles as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible